الاستعدادات لبدا الفعاليه هنا المسير في
دار الحسين نتابع الخياله همم
في هذه همم اللقطات التي تصلنا مباشره هذا
العرض
العسكري الذي سيبدا بالمسير نتابع اذا
واياكم هذه الصور
لفعاليات ضرب لسيل التي تنطلق طبعا
احتفالا
بختان كاس العالم نتابع ايضا نشاهد الان
الحافله حافله منتخب الارجنتين التي ستمر
من دار لوسيل يعتليها
لاعبوا منتخب الارجنتين الذين فازوا وتوجو
بكاس العالم قطر
2002/22 اول بطوله في بلد عربي
اذا اختتام البطوله
بطوله كاس العالم
يتزامن مع اليوم الوطني لدوله قطر
لذا نشاهد هذا المسير الاحتفالي
الذي سيكون خلفنا مباشره في درب الوسيل
خلف هذا الاستديو الخاص للجزيره في دار
لوسيل لتغطيه فعاليات كاس العالم مشاهد
امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني
الذي على ما يبدو يتواجد على شرفه في درب
الحسين لمواقبه هذه الفعاليات الى جانبه
طبعا جاني الفانتينو رئيس اتحاد كره القدم
فيفا
هذا المنتخب الارجنتيني على حافله تحمل
علم الارجنتين
ستمر من هنا
نتابع لاعبي منتخب الارجنتين
يستقلون هذه الحافله
التي غادرت الملعب الان وتتجه نحو درب
لوسيل
ليحيى لاعبوه منتخب الارجنتين الجماهير
المتواجده على طرفين
الخياله
يرافقون ايضا هذه الشاحنه التي تتزين
بالالوان الزرقاء
والصفراء على منتخب الارجنتين الذي حصل
على كاس العالم مشاهد دي ماريا
وليونيل ميسي القائد
وادي بول ايضا
لاعبون
باريسون في منتخب الارجنتين في هذه
البطوله
ايضا الارجنتين
بالبطوله ميسي افضل لاعب ناشئ ايضا وافضل
حارس مرمى
لمنتخب الارجنتين وبطبيعه الحال لقب كاس
العالم قطر
كمبيون ابطال تشامبيونز على قميص منتخب
الارجنتين
وهم فعلا كانوا ابطال في هذه البطوله
لثلاثه اهداف
سجل الى الخلفيه
ثلاثيه لمنتخب فرنسا بينما سجل ميسي هدفان
اذا امير دوله قطر على شلفه في دار الحسين
او هذه الحافله
[تصفيق]
وعليها لاعبون
للالقاب بهذه البطوله عاده
يعني هذه الفعاليه تتم في الدوله التي
تفوز نشاهد عاده حافلات تحمل اللاعبين في
دولتهم عندما يصلون الى
بلدانهم ولكن هنا في دربلو سيل نشهد هذه
الفاعليه اريد ان قطر يلوح
للجمهور الذي يتفاعل معه كما اسلفت سابقا
الجمهور العربي من كل الجنسيات فرح بهذه
البطوله العربيه التي نظمتها قطر وكانت
ناجحه بكل المقاييس بحسب تصريحات جاني
انفانتينو بطوله خاليه من الشغب خاليه من
الاحداث من احداث سكر
كسرت الكثير من الارقام القياسيه
بما فيها ايضا حضور مباراه واحده حوالي
89000 مشاهد في مباراه الارجنتين والمكسيك
في استاد لوسين حوالي ثلاثه ملايين
و400,000
مشاهد شاهد المباريات في الملاعب الملاعب
المختلفه الملاعب الثمانيه التي انشئت في
دوله قطر استعدادا لهذه البطوله خمسه
مليارات نسمه حول العالم تابعوا هذه
البطوله على شاشات التلفزه
ارقام كثيره حققت في هذه البطوله منها
وصول اول فريق عربي افريقي الى المربع
الذهبي منتخب المغرب ايضا المنتخبات
العربيه الاخرى المشاركه جسيمه السعوديه
وتونس حققوا انجازات بفوز السعوديه على
الارجنتين وفوز تونس على فرنسا
[تصفيق]
بعد ان توج منتخب الارجنتين بكاس العالم
قطر
2022 بعد تعادله بثلاثه اهداف لمثلها مع
منتخب مع منتخب فرنسا ومثنى الفوز بطربات
الجزاء الترجيحيه باربعه مقابل اثنان
لاحظوا التفاعل من الجماهير المتواجده على
طرفين
الطريق
الجمال تتصدر الجمل العربي يتصدر هذه
المسيره
[تصفيق]
طبعا
فرقه موسيقيه
في هذا المسير
كاس العالم مرفوع عاليا
بايدي ابطال العالم النسخه العربيه قطر
منتخب الارجنتيني
استطاع المشاهد العربي
ويشاهد هذه البطوله مباشره
بثلاثه بسهوله دون احداث تذكر
اذا المنتخب الارجنتين
على الحافله
يمر بعد قليل
خلف
ستوديو الجزيره هنا
الاولى في هذه الصور المباشره
[تصفيق]
رشا القطري
في الصوره وهذا العرض والاحتفاليه
[تصفيق]
اذا المتابع
سيارات ايضا رسميات وبا
[موسيقى]
كر الشرطه القطريه
ايضا حمايه المنتخبات
الذين شاركوا في صناعه
هذه البطوله وفي
نجاحها الخياله ايضا
[موسيقى]
يمر من خلفنا تماما
مسيره تكميميه لكل من شارك بهذه البطوله
[تصفيق]